hello rejects Lou Reed its Greg here
right here and this is Johnny this is
Johnny I was looking at analytics today
and I noticed how a lot of our subs have
been coming in from India lately you
know they say you got a tent to the
subscribers like if most of our subs are
from the United States fruit but you
know what we got a lot of support and a
lot of comments a lot of requests coming
in from India fans now so we're like you
know ones of India yeah from fans of
India countries so cool can you talk
about more of their to vulture heart we
got a lot of subs coming in and I was
like you know what I usually just wait
to you know what if way to put my
brother's request Jabby to a to go and
watch a video with him at his place if
it's an Indian trailer and review it but
today I was like you know what I don't
want to drive there tonight means a
little hard there sometimes so I'm gonna
watch this trailer with John this is for
the film dumb I don't know how to say
I'm really badly gone pronouncing words
I don't know dumb gall and comes out on
Christmas it is three hours long
oh good whoa dude that is a long film I
loved movies long like wow they are like
they their attention span must be much
longer those oh yeah no cuz the
Americans are impatient beings unless
it's like okay is very special exactly
yeah this is a double movie I know if
you a little bit about very little about
I know it's a biopic about a father who
he raised on like his daughters to be
wrestlers and and in this part of the
world where they're at it's really much
frowned upon like - because I think a
big message of the film from what I was
reading online was about how about he
deals with equal rights and equality
that you know like you mean if I'm not
sure let's just watch the trailer maybe
I'll be able to phrase what I'm trying
to say really explain yeah yeah I know
what to expect there's there's subtitles
on this one this is gonna make it is
gonna help us out a lot
yeah visually enjoy Green is fun Disney
intro Disney India this according to
secure 5 points for himself
that's one the wrestling champion wore
dope that Mecca despaired any update
that's a cool line oh nice man that's
one thing
oh you're speaking my language now
that's like Karate Kid Cudi I'm a daddy
Sbrocco
mmm-hmm they steal a gold medal on
Jamaica or not dr. Tom Coburn a big
talker katakana sku gorgeous day come on
Vika
so clock didn't go sup super long well
whatever wise up don't baby told you yet
it's got four girls up
oh man he dug when I met dad's in this
major supplying stead of today put a
curse again hmm interesting
[Music]
daddy I'm on again his daughters did it
when a monitor dip double bit on Amara
nice down
oh yeah
you bought me so much mana he can call
the goal of that tour another Jody
oh whoa that's our exercise I know any
sympathy on italki no snugly but silver
gt2 are genetically looked an average
Iranian college et salma hayek missile
and each other better
[Music]
which is the sound crunching
[Music]
that girl
oh my god their mission oh right oh hey
man that movie looks sweet that looks
like a sweet [ __ ] film yeah
Disney's live-action India films like
way better than American oh I would go
watch this in December oh yeah dude that
looks like awesome I don't know how the
arcs of this is gonna go I'm not exactly
100% sure what the messages of this are
but I can tell you right now that there
are some definitely intriguing
characters no I'm not familiar with the
actual true story that this is based on
regardless I'd Sastry
I found myself before any of the cool
[ __ ] started happening I was very
invested in this this character like you
know that his father having that been
that you know the man nightmare of
having you know saw nothing but
daughters and because that can be scary
for a lot of men and I met fathers who
have only daughters as children but I
like the approach here it wasn't because
the approach was you know the father was
kind of coming from a meaningful yet
kind of a selfish perch a place you know
that's about winning the goal but
there's still a lot more meaning to it
it's not like a greedy kind of desire
that's it's a very like symbolic kind of
desire to make it to make his country
proud yeah I'm actually curious as to
how this film will handle that because
there's a lot you can you can do with
that cuz you can add a nuance to that
story about I don't know like when
you're so determined on a goal that
you're gonna make your kids see ya like
that can be kind of an abusive situation
like yeah so like I'm interested in as
to how much of those you know levels
they're gonna explore with it I mean it
seems like it's definitely like a female
empowerment story oh absolutely
definitely especially with that last
line that is a dope last line you think
our girls are lesser than boys Oh
boom right there it's a rhetorical
question and it's an exclamation hey I
just think the dad character is very
intriguing because even though he feels
like Oh
- pointed in and like it seems like in a
way that he's kind of like just
disappointed with himself and lied in a
lot of ways and he just feels down on
his luck with the fact that he only had
daughters and it's it's it's an interest
but you still see he's probably a good
dad still he's probably still someone
who loves his children all right yeah I
mean he doesn't seem like a you know
like I kicked him or something yeah yeah
he just seems very determined and and
quietly passionate I'm cool with them
placing that front and center of this
man who wanted his child to live out the
legacy that he wished to fulfill I feel
like a lot of the times that's either
tried to do a little bit more not as not
as in in front of the page it was
sometimes its subtext yeah I know what
that means but just that that way that
seemed played out when the boys came all
beaten up and because we knew the minor
plot of this somehow that was probably
the daughters who kick their asses
that was so sweet because it wasn't
something of like this guy has daughters
he's like you know what [ __ ] it I'm
gonna train them anyway yeah he like saw
that there's biters inside of his
daughter so so he stole yeah asset along
to them he saw past it and realized that
it didn't matter like yeah he saw like
all it takes is that spark and that's
you know that's the thing that matters
yeah and these girls look like they're
really kicking some ass some of those
training sequences like what is that
thing where they're like I have their
backs are so their head is in the ground
I don't know I mean it must be some kind
of we wouldn't do that it hardly to you
look here this is not a relaxing this is
not a yoga studio in Studio City
California is rough there just seems to
be a lot of life and passion in this
story that's being told with a lot of
great messages in there and themes
what's surprising to me about it is it
doesn't look cheesy it actually looks
really well told in an inspiring way it
is very effective I mean it is also
sweeping at least this trailer is very
anything all that all the hues are
really up hot it just looks like bad ass
though
yeah but it's also you know like yeah
there is something about the story where
you really do just want to see it
through and you really do invest or at
least I did like I watched it and I was
like yeah I really want to see like you
know I'm please like succeed I want this
to succeed
see yeah it does kind of grab you in
with a really kinda universal thing
again there's an action film called
Hanna nan stars uh some people call her
SAR she wrote you wrote
Saoirse Ronan you're not the whisperer
if I'm looking for the name Kyle Keisha
Saoirse editors or she used mice Marcia
Marcia how do you know they're Swiffer
any of like feels like a baseball card
stats
um holographics I'm sorry sir own it but
in the beginning of that movie what I
loved Howard because there are character
is a 15 year old girl and then the first
scene that you see that happen is she's
fighting Eric Bennett in the snow and
then later on you find out that it's her
father and he's been training her all
these years that's like a much more
heightened plot about spies and [ __ ]
but I said I could get a resemblance
here of that because I love seeing
badass females and stories female so you
can kick ass where they're not just like
they're a cool fighter but they're also
just a cool character you got like these
girls here who just seem like really
cool characters and it also seems to be
an emotional depth here that doesn't
seem to be in your face about it cuz it
did I didn't see a scene in this trailer
that it was like you've been forcing us
to do this as a whole time like them
having to meet maybe there's a scene in
the trip in the movie itself well that's
yeah but that's the stuff I'm curious
about with this like you know and how
much were they gonna dig into their
message cuz it's an interesting point
I love seeing badass female characters
too that are still kind of allowed to
still be female you know cuz sometimes
it's just like they're a glorified dude
I'm really curious to see how this movie
tells it seems like it's got its
heartless it's those feeling and
important badass females to me are like
same thing when I see like a badass
human character you know like here it
was a guy I think that if you're
emotional but you can also kick ass
that's the coolest character and I'm so
that's my fan it's like the best version
of that is one you know they're still
like essentially female but you know
they have all these other qualities I'm
gonna definitely keep a lookout for what
gets a release in the United States
because it's actually a trailer from
like any of these Indian films I'm
always so impressed by how they're shot
yeah they're so beautiful and we got be
incredible they're all good they're not
like that cinematographer who worked on
Jagger they're really strife they're
really they're really striking and
really you know composed you know
there's lots of interesting living hard
life and yet and even in this we're like
you know it's it's not as like garish as
maybe some of the older you know the
older Indian cinema is even the sort of
more modern color palette still feels
very saturated and very lush well this
comes out December 23rd I might spend
December 25th Christmas Day not at some
mass that saint-charles smash smash
let's say Sunday Mass oh I don't know if
it falls on a Sunday well September 23rd
might be a Friday or a Wednesday yeah
never a Monday thanks guys for
recommending that to us it seems like
it's an important story for for ending
history it's not just a oh really
cool-looking movie it's also like in
this is also part of our history yeah
and hey that's important too you know
like that bring more culture into the
world spear you know like help us to
stop ignoring other places in the world
it's my cat guy the copper I have
another one named Tawhiti will come up
here mmm Rashad anyway rejects if you're
new to the channel you can subscribe
today and get accepted John get accepted
I'll mail you I think I might have
actually accepted I might think I might
have actually come up with a way to end
the videos that I like the desert still
has that no not more than that be help
all right
rejects subscribe today and get accepted
that's cool it's just as cool as this
trailer John is raising tsageri on
Facebook no he's not on Twitter and
Instagram and he is also the social
media manager of facebook.com slash the
real rejects and facebook.com slash Blum
house if you guys haven't heard abloom
house they're [ __ ] popular take care